and now here are the nominees for
achievement in sound mixing ad astra
gary Rydstrom Tom Johnson and macula
Ford versus Ferrari Palmer see David
DeMarco and Stephen a mile Joker Tom Oh
sonic Dean Sebastian and third native
1917 Mark Taylor and Stuart Wilson
once upon a time in Hollywood Michael
Minkler Christian pimenta and markula
and the Oscar goes to 1917 Mark Taylor
and Stuart Wilson this is the first
Oscar and third nomination for Mark
Taylor this is the first Oscar win
six nomination for Stuart
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I would like to accept this award on
behalf of the entire 1917 sound team
each one of whom did outstanding work on
this film from my guys in the trenches
to Mark's team in the studio for their
incredible support I think there are
families Victoria Ava and to our
producers Callum Jana and Pippa and Sam
Mendes none of us would be here without
you thank you I'd like to thank Ollie
and his great team Rachel
Mike Bentham Shambo Lee Smith our editor
all the guys who gave such a great score
to work with Robby and the guys at Gold
crest Rob Carlson and bebe thank you so
much
[Applause]